Les architectes, ceux qui vivent dans les grandes villes
Eh Beh ils savent pas la vie de banlieue comment c'est etc..
Ils font de grands bâtiments
Après, comme le bâtiment il est grand
Eh bah après les gens ils veulent pas vivre dedans
Vous êtes racistes ?
Parce que je suis noir ?
Non, non non
Calmez vous
Ah les Ratail dans tout ça la
Ah là là faut sortir tout ça de la France
Je connais pas les français de souche
C'est rare qu'on en voit des pur français au collège
Peut être que j'en ai déjà rencontré mais peut être j'ai déjà oublié en fait
Moi je les rencontre à Paris et je les considère comme des personnes normales
Tous mes rêves ils tournent autour de la mode
Tout le monde s'habille en jogging, baskets
Ils ont le style clonage
J'aimerais être Obama
Il a un charisme fou, il sait marcher
Il dégage quelque chose
François Hollande quand il marche heuu.. c'est pas trop ça
Il y a aucun épisode de Mickey que j'aime
ça me fait peur Mickey
C'est une souris qui parle, qui chante et qui danse
Etre amoureux ? Chais pas
C'est quand tu penses que t'as trouvé la personne qui te manquait
Ils se font des bisous sur la bouche.
* Rires *
Ça rajoute un truc à la vie